our first speaker is Christina will be
talking remotely about efficient
exploitation efficiently exploiting
model structures in network causal
inference with or without knowledge of
the network so this is an online talk if
you have any questions just pick up
saying I have a question I will bring
the mic to you so that the speaker can
hear your question okay uh Krishna
please go ahead great thank you so much
suvik and I'm really um I'm really
bummed I couldn't be there in person
however I will be coming in person very
soon so
um I'll be coming in person in the end
of October for the next workshop and
I'll be staying to the end of to the end
of the program so I'm really excited to
meet many of you then soon
um and so I'm excited to tell you about
this work on uh causal inference with
networks and so hopefully it'll be um I
hope to kind of introduce a new and
interesting problem too to all of you
and I think it's a space where there's a
lot of uh space for contribution in
terms of thinking about how to
incorporate Network structure
um all right so let me just start with a
application so of course the last few
years have all been uh you know Cove has
been on the top of our minds and you
know the the CDC uh put out statistics
on um the the effect of of mask wearing
so how much do you reduce your risk if
you wear a mask how much do you reduce
your risk give people around you wear a
mask and you can think how does actually
sit how is that statistic actually
computed
um you can imagine one way to uh try to
estimate it is to
um look at observational data of people
wearing uh who in the population who
wear Macs and some people who don't
measure the health outcomes of um of
whether people get covered or not and to
just estimate the average difference in
the uh covet testing results between
mask wearing and not masking wearing
people
but of course there's
um natural uh actually two issues with
this uh Pro uh with uh this approach
first of all uh there could be
confounding if we're using observational
data so people who choose to wear a mask
may actually have different
susceptibility and pre-existing
conditions and so when you're measuring
the difference in health outcomes
between mask wearing and not mask
squaring Behavior people you may not
actually be estimating the effect of the
Mask wearing you might be estimating
differences in the population's wearing
masks versus not
uh so this is a reason why
um oftentimes we turn to using
randomized experiments when we're trying
to estimate something causal to try to
get around this confounding issue
however there's still an issue here that
even when we if we were to use a
randomized experiment to try to estimate
the effect of mass wearing and the the
challenge is that actually your
individual outcomes your health outcomes
is affected not only by your own action
of whether you wear a mask or not but
also by whether the people around you
wore a mask or not
this is what we're going to refer to as
Network interference so when you're the
network the treatment
assigned to your network actually
affects your outcome
I'm going to give one more example I'm
not a big example suppose I am LinkedIn
and I want to evaluate a new social
media news feed algorithm so I'm trying
to decide between uh the new proposed
news feed algorithm and my status quo
um so what I could do is I could run a
randomized experiment randomly assign a
fraction of the users to this new
algorithm and then compare the
performance on some metrics such as user
engagement or activity and and compare
the performance of the new algorithm
versus the status quo algorithm however
again we run into this network
interference issue where the
individual's behavior on the social
media platform have an influence on each
other so whether even if I'm put in the
control group and I got my status quo
the status quo algorithm my experience
on the platform depends if a chain will
change if my neighbor was assigned to
the new treatment because they will
maybe generating different and a content
for my newsfeed
so let me step back first and set up
what is going to be the causal inference
task what's the what's the thing we're
going to try to estimate and and how
does it have to do with the network so
first of all what we're going to want to
do is evaluate the effect of a proposed
treatment versus control on a population
of size n which is going to be connected
via some known Network
for the purpose of this talk we're going
to assume that the network is static
um uh but actually a very interesting
question is to actually think about a
setting where Dynamic networks as well
so I'm gonna posit a potential outcomes
function y which is a function that
which specifies all hypothetical
outcomes it's a function that Maps uh
from the vector of all treatment
um treatment assignments to outcomes
over individuals so in particular
um we're gonna consider binary setting
where an individual either gets
treatment or control so the treatment
Vector is in 0 1 to the n and it maps to
an outcome over all to n individuals so
that's R to then
foreign
the thing we want to estimate is going
to be the total treatment effect is the
difference between the outcomes of the
average outcomes of the population under
the vector where you fully treat
everyone that's the all one's vector and
the vector where you where nobody is
treated the all zeros vector
this is a an estimate that is
particularly relevant for settings such
as the one I described in LinkedIn where
the the goal of running the experiment
is to decide whether you commit to this
new treatment or in the new proposed
algorithm or revert to the status quo
algorithm
and the challenge of causal inference is
that we only observe data from a single
treatment effector so imagine I I run a
single experiment and now that
experiment is you know I have to choose
a treatment Vector to assign for that
experiment but given the observation
from that one experiment I want to
figure out how to uh estimate these
causal estimates
so
um we're gonna need a key assumption and
um to contrast it with the Assumption
that's often used in the literature the
classical work often assumes What's
called the stable unit treatment value
assumption this is an assumption that
imposes an individual's outcome only
depends on the individual there is the
question is oh okay yes
yeah uh so I I figure this might be
something you're going to explain in a
bit but just to be clear the are we
assuming that the potential outcomes
function is deterministic
or um I'm gonna yes I'm gonna assume
that's deterministic it's actually very
easy to add
um independent noise
um the the actually something that would
be very interesting to to think about
extensions would be a setting where
potential outcomes function actually
could be
um if it could be time varying if you're
actually in a
um uh in a a dynamic setting but here
we're going to assume a deterministic
potential outcome function
um yeah
uh independent independent noise is easy
to add correlated noise is harder yeah
yeah thanks good question
um
so uh so we're gonna want to uh of
course relax this this classical uh
assumption on stable unit treatment
value assumption instead we'll assume
what's called neighborhood interference
so neighborhood interference an
individual's outcome only depends on the
treatment neighborhood meaning that if I
have uh so that so here I'm using Y uh
sub I to index that potential outcomes
of individual I individual eyes outcome
under two treatment vectors Z and Z
Prime is going to be the same as long as
the assignments of treatments to the
neighborhood of I so that's denoted by
Script and I uh for these two vectors is
the same so if the neighborhood
assignments are the same uh then the the
outcome should be the same
and so it allows you to reduce the
um so simplify the potential outcomes
function to be only a function of the
assignments to the neighbors and here
I'm going to consider this neighborhood
and some n uh script n to include the
individual eye itself so the
neighborhood is going to be myself and
my neighbors
and furthermore we'll be considering the
red the experimental this uh randomized
experiment setting whereas treatments
are going to be assigned randomly to
avoid confounding
um between the treatment and the
individual in an individual's
characteristics and when when I say
randomized design that's going to refer
to the distribution of the treatment
Vector Z so in particular here we're
going to again consider a potential
outcomes function which is deterministic
so the only thing that's random here is
going to be with respect to the
randomness in Z not not uh and and yeah
again the treatment Vector Z is the only
thing that's random not the uh not the
function itself
so to uh I guess
um also set up what is the a standard
classical a B test that might be run
um under the the classical super
assumption
um the natural thing to do
um is to take an individual that's the
individual here and randomly assign the
individual to treatment or control
um and under sutva the again the outcome
only depends on this individual's
assignment
um so if I want to estimate this total
treatment effect a very natural s demand
is to consider or estimator is to
confuse the difference in means
estimator the difference it means
estimator simply takes the empirical
mean of the outcomes of all the
individuals assigned to treatment that's
group a and subtracts the the average
outcomes of all individuals assigned to
Group B that's the control
because the natural thing to do and you
can see that because you're we're
randomizing the the the treatments
assignments and because of the stable
unit treatment value assumption then
indeed the difference in means estimator
is unbiased and uh it's a efficient
estimator for the total treatment effect
but what happens if you have Network
interference so under Network
interference the individual's outcome
now depends on its neighborhood and now
the total treatment effect s demand you
should think of it as
the average population outcome under two
hypothetical scenarios one setting when
all of individuals are assigned to
treatment and the other when all
individuals sign to control
and the yet the data that we're actually
collecting from our a B test again if we
randomly assigned individuals to
treatment or control is going to be the
outcome of that individual under
whatever happens to be the assignment of
its neighborhood so even if I assign
individual eye to treatment it could be
that it has other neighbors that were
assigned to control and if even if I
assigned I to control it could have had
neighbors that are assigned to treatment
and as a result the observation you
collect is may be neither of the values
that that are in the S demand you want
to estimate so it might it might not
match either of the outcomes under fully
treated or fully controlled
so again naively using a difference in
means estimate you can see that it will
uh you know you can easily construct uh
scenarios in which incurs significant
bias
and so a question we're going to be
answering and asking is how do we use
data collected from such an A B test to
estimate a total treatment effect under
interference
so I'll just pause here and see if
there's any questions
okay
um so uh to to kind of uh first tell a a
a a natural Baseline
um that you could that will kind of
compare against uh so if I do Bernoulli
design meaning I every individuals is
independently assigned to treatment with
probability P I could use what's called
an Harvest Thompson estimator it's
really an inverse propensity or inverse
probability weighted estimator where for
each individual eye I weight its outcome
by the this difference between the
ratios of of the uh this this ratio here
is the indicator function of if the in
the individual and its neighborhood are
all assigned to treatment divided by the
probability of that event minus the
indicator function if the individual in
this neighborhood is assigned to control
divided by the probability of that event
as well
um however you can already see that this
estimator may not be that uh stable or
it it may not perform very well because
the probabilities in these denominators
are actually really small if my degree
is high so in particular the variance
under Bernoulli design of this estimator
uh scales the main thing to focus on is
a scale is like 1 over n times P to the
D where D is the degree of the let's say
the degree of the graph so for a uniform
degree graph
so here um the again the costly part is
that this variant scales exponentially
in the degree of the graph
and and uh so again the question is
whether we can do better and in
particular what we'll what we'll discuss
today is we'll present a
um a new way of measuring the complexity
of the model which will then um allow us
to to construct estimators for which the
variance actually scales exponentially
in that
um that new complexity measure
um rather than the degree of the graph
okay so a quick comment on what um the
the literature looks like there's kind
of two approaches to this base one is a
non-parametric approaches that focus on
using clever randomized design but they
demand heavily on the graph being
clusterable so for example if your graph
is fully disconnected then a natural
thing to do is you just randomize each
over each of these clusters
independently and then instead your
estimator scales with one over the
number of clusters rather than one over
the number of individuals
um another thing to you could do if your
graph is not clusterable is that you can
construct a clustering for your graph so
here if I can for example choose cluster
centers that are kind of nicely spread
apart and then assign every individual
to the cluster Center that's closest to
it and then given such a clustering I
could then randomize over these clusters
um it can be computationally complex and
not all
randomized experimental platforms are
set up to run cluster Anonymous design
but if you could
um the you can again Define the Harvest
constant estimator under such a cluster
randomized design and
um and a a beautiful work by Johann
ugander and his student actually showed
that if you have a k restricted a Kappa
restricted growth graph meaning that the
neighborhood size does not grow too fast
if you use this randomized cluster
randomized design then you get a
variance which uh again that you can the
again the part to focus sign is that
scale size 1 over n times p and most
notably it no longer scales
exponentially with the degree in terms
of the exponent of P
um so this is the kind of result and the
gain that we would like to get however
without the without the the cost of
having to run a complex randomized
design and maybe without having to make
restrictions on the uh the graph
structure beyond the degree
another approach is to take a parametric
approach that essentially the the most
common model is to assume a linear model
with respect to known features and then
you just reduce it to regression
um you can extend it Beyond linear
models and use machine learning
approaches as well the limitations that
you do require you need to have a fairly
simple model class so you need a lot
more data than the parameters to
identify the model and then the number
of data points you have is only the
number of individuals in your population
so it means that the number of
parameters has to be significantly and
smaller so it doesn't allow for full
heterogeneity over your population
furthermore they most of these
approaches assume what's called
Anonymous interference that the model
does not depend my potential outcomes
does not depend on the identity of
individual treated but only on the
number of individuals treated and it can
be very fragile to modeling the
specification
furthermore all of these solutions they
require either not exact knowledge of
the network or at least approximate
knowledge of the network
um so what we'll look at today is how do
we exploit model structure and how does
that allow us to then you know in some
settings uh remove the requirement of
having knowledge of the network and and
in general
um you know construct estimators where
the performance is going to depend on an
appropriate notion of the model
structure
so to introduce the model we'll look at
um again we'll first note we'll first
observe that because I'm in uh the treat
the treatment Vector Z is binary we can
express the potential outcomes function
as a polynomial in Z where here all I'm
doing is writing um here this is um the
I'm summing over all subsets of the
neighborhood AIS is the outcome of of
individual I when exactly set s is
treated and then this products here is
the indicator function
um it's it's expressing the indicator
function of if set s is treated and the
complement of s is not treated
but as you can see uh from this
expression that the polynomial degree of
the potential outcomes model is is
always going to be bounded by the degree
of the graph the degree or the graph
degree of you know the size of his
neighborhood
um so a natural way to then measure kind
of complexity of this model would be say
uh it would be to measure it with the
polynomial degree of the model so you
know it could be a much simpler model in
which the degree of this potential
outcomes function is significantly
smaller than the degree of the graph
um and so if you had a degree beta
polynomial potential outcomes model then
we can express our our
um our potential outcomes function by
only summing over subsets of size
bounded by Beta
so the number of parameters in the model
at large is still scales as n times
roughly D to the beta because for each
individual I it has its own coefficients
in this model this coefficient c i comma
s and for each subset s that's going to
be roughly D to the beta or there are
roughly D to the beta subsets since
you're choosing
um sets of size beta out of a
neighborhood size of d
um to kind of motivate this uh one
example that motivates this setting of
low degree polynomial or um you can also
think of it as low order interactions
because our polynomial is a polynomial
of uh it's over
um a binary Vector
um so an example that can motivate it is
if you have I have an individual with a
very large neighborhood has many many
friends but amongst that friendship
group there could be sub-community so in
particular for example I have you know
my family that's one group one
subcommunicing my high school friends or
my college friends are my colleagues and
each of these would be separate
subcommunities that are connected within
but not connected across
um and it's plausible that my potential
outcomes could be additive across these
subgroups but the function that governs
the the effect on me within a subgroup
is not necessarily additive
um so it could be because I know that
individuals within the same sub group
kind of share information that if to a
few of my individuals are are treated it
may not
um the the kind of effect on me may not
be uh kind of uh separately independent
or additive
um and so in this example the the
polynomial degree would be bounded at
most by this the size of any of these
subcommunities which could be smaller
again than the large degree
another
um uh model which is uh a specific
setting of our model is when beta equals
one so the you can also think of it as
the the linear setting or we're gonna we
refer to as the heterogeneous additive
Network effect setting because on when
when beta equals one you can write your
potential outcomes function as simply a
sum over
um uh these so here the first term is
the Baseline effect it's if whether or
not I'm treated this is the my the
outcome that's always there and then if
I'm treated z i
um then there is an additive effect to
CII and for each one of my neighbors K
that is treated that's indicated by ZK
then there's an additive effect cik on
me
and so you can you can again visualize
this model
um using in either Matrix vector and
notation on the left or a graph notation
on the right where on the right hand
side uh the self the self um self edges
um the weight on the self edges is the
direct effect of me being treated by
myself the weight on edge from me to
another individual is the effect that my
treatment has on that individual and the
the weight
marked on the Node itself is the
Baseline effect the effect the
um the outcome that is not affected by
whether I'm treated or not
and so if I treated a set of individuals
I marked them as red and I I also Mark
all of their outgoing edges as red as
well
so
um some nice properties about even the
simplest uh additive uh model is that it
does allow for full heterogeneity in
these coefficients
um the coefficients can be positive or
negative the number of coefficients can
be as large as the number of edges
um so it's definitely larger than the
number of possible measurements
um and this it's very easy to add means
your independent measurement noise as
well to the potential outcomes function
and that doesn't really change any of
the results
okay so I guess the question is going to
be can we how do we exploit this type of
structure I'll call it low order
interaction structure and what we do is
we'll present new estimators Whose
performance is characterized by the new
complexity measure so in particular this
polynomial degree which we'll denote by
Beta is again always bounded by the
degree of the graph and so what we'll
expect is that the variance of our s our
estimators so our estimates will be
unbiased and the variance is going to
scale as 1 over n times P to the beta
rather than P to the D
and we'll present results under two two
types of experimental designs the first
one I'm going to call staggered rollout
design it's a richer experimental setup
where you can take measurements over
multiple time steps and and the Richer
experimental setup actually allows us to
enable graph agnostic estimators so
estimators that do not require knowledge
of the graph at all the second setup is
a more classical experimental setup
where I have a Bernoulli design a single
measurement
and the results here are going to allow
for randomized design where the
treatments are non-uniform but it does
require knowledge of the graph
um so let me first tell you about our
um first set of results so consider an
experimental design where you have
um where you are rolling out the
treatment in multiple periods of time
um and this is actually you know rolling
out your treatment in multiple materials
over time is actually already used in
practice because oftentimes even if I
want to run an experiment with say 15 of
the population I still want to be
cautious and um you know first treat one
percent then two percent five percent
seven percent ten percent twelve percent
just to make sure along the process of
my uh my my treatment plan that you know
nothing goes wrong if there's potential
risks
um and so so in particular we do impose
a monotonicity that the treatments are
nested once an individual is treated
they remain treated through the period
and um
and the uh within each of the periods
the um the assignments are are assigned
according to Bernoulli design so
conditional Bernoulli design because
conditioned on you not having been
treated before then you're independently
assigned treatment or not in each
subsequent stage
so what we show is that if the potential
outcomes model has a polynomial degree
of beta then it without have requiring
knowledge of the network we propose an
estimator which is unbiased under the
staggered role at Bernoulli design that
has variant scaling as this quantity
here again the main thing you should pay
attention to is that the exponent now
depends on beta rather than the degree D
and so indeed it means that if I have a
much simpler model with stronger
structure then we can get significantly
better results than um than if I were to
not you know ignore that structure and
not particularly exploit it
so the the kind of key aha is that this
ability to take multiple measurements
via staggered wallet design actually
enables estimation of this total
treatment effect without knowledge of
the network
and um the key Insight is that you can
actually reduce it to polynomial
interpolation so if I have a beta degree
polynomial potential outcomes model and
a Bernoulli randomized design the
average outcome of the whole of the
outcomes of the population is going to
be a beta degree polynomial with respect
to the treatment fraction P so here I've
just written that the expected value of
the average outcomes over the whole
population
under Bernoulli p is going to be again a
p a beta degree polynomial in p and so
the key uh the I guess the key Insight
is that the total treatment effect is
simply the difference between this
polynomial evaluated at one and zero and
if you if we can Implement a staggered
rollout design we can get estimates for
this polynomial at uh at multiple levels
of of this treatment fraction p and so
if I have a beta degree a polynomial I
minimally need beta plus one different
treatment
um uh yeah I need to observe the this
function at beta Swan different
treatment levels in order to learn the
polynomial
um and so the estimator is not
particularly interesting to show because
really it's just probably just literally
using a polynomial uh extra
interpolation and applying it to the
estimates uh to the measure to the
empirical uh measurements of the average
uh uh population average outcomes
but I will tell you uh the the example
for the specific case of the linear
setting
um it's uh kind of the the it's very
intuitive and um very simple to explain
so so in the linear setting it reduces
the setting of uh uh the the the this
notion of staggered rollout now for a
linear setting because the degree is one
I only need two measurements so in
particular the most reasonable
um kind of setting is to assume that I
have uh these knowledge of average bass
lines so before the experiment I just
estimate what the population average of
the kind of status quo is and then I run
a single experiment and having access to
that previous average baselines gives me
that extra data point that I need for
this result so uh with an estimate of
its average Baseline for any randomized
design such that the marginal tree
probability is equal then the the
estimator we propose is the following
one you take the average population
outcome of your experiment subtract off
the average Baseline and scale it by 1
over P this is an estimator that's
unbiased for any network under this
under our model and
um again the the thing to observe from
this estimator is that nowhere did we
need to use knowledge of the network to
compute it and under Bernoulli design
the variance scales as one over P times
n which is the best that you could
expect because we're treating P
individuals out of n
and so so I'll give you a visual picture
of what the result is that the total
treatment effect under this model is
just the sum of the weighted edges
um so some of the weights over all the
edges
um and because the the again the
outcomes
um the the outcomes are the sum of the
the nodes plus the edge weights and you
want to subtract off the the outcomes
under control which are all the notes
and so you so the total treatment effect
um is nothing but the sum of the weights
over all the edges
and if you treat an individual I again I
remember referring it to is it activates
an outgoing Edge or you mark it by Red
and the measurement that you're taking
is so the the kind of action taken the
treatment affects outgoing edges the
measurements are on incoming edges so
the measurement I take are sums of my
incoming red colored edges plus the
um uh node node value itself
and the estimator that we construct we
can show that it's just the sum of all
these red activated edges now it becomes
more clear to see that um
so is that that even though the
measurements are taking the sums of the
incoming edges by just
averaging all the outcomes together and
subtracting off the average base signs
which are the node values what we do is
we get an S we're essentially Computing
the sum of all the the red edges so all
the outgoing edges of treated
individuals which we're going to refer
to the influence of an individual as the
sum of its outgoing edges
so this kind of mapping allows us to
show that the the uh this network
interference setting is equivalent to
thinking about a setting um without
navigation interference a survey
sampling setting where I have
individuals and this this parameter L
just denotes their influence on the
network that's the sum of the outgoing
edges and for every individual so so
whereas the estimator on the left
um uh uh what it effectively does is it
does is sums up the values of these
influence terms for all treated
individuals and so simply by randomly
selecting a subset of the uh of the
individuals to treat uniformly at random
we get a uniform estimate of a a we were
Computing the the empirical average of a
uniformly selected subset of the
population and so the kind of the the
simple inside is that given these
Baseline estimates this network causal
inference really as easy as estimating a
population mean
so once you do the reduction then it's
easy to show in biases you can actually
compute the variance for um for other
designs Beyond Bernoulli and ask which
uh which randomized design does better
and uh and furthermore you know the the
dependence on the network was very
minimal so you can even have a fully
dense Network as long as these um these
the the influence of any individual is
bounded
we did run some experiments that I won't
really
um uh dwell on but I'll show you a few
pictures the key in uh I guess the one
thing I want to comment is we compared
our estimator against uh a regression uh
regression estimator using OLS as well
as difference in means estimators this
is uh the results on the additive
Network effect sending where beta equals
one our estimator is the one in blue so
what I'm plotting is the relative bias
of our the estimator the Shaded region
is the um the the
confidence or actually is the standard
deviation uh the empirical standard
deviation and
um the the plot on the left shows what
are we're varying the population size
the plot in the middle we're varying the
relative magnitude of the Direct effects
versus Indra effect so how much is of
the effect is coming from the network
and on the right we're varying the
treatment budget and in all of the plots
you can see that our estimator the blue
one really does the best it's the only
one that's unbiased and furthermore the
variance is not very high
um the second set of plots is uh under
the a degree two model so here
um our estimator is still the only one
that's unbiased it's variance is a
little higher and
um under certain parameter settings it's
comparable to one of the least squares
estimators as well
so in the last few minutes I'll tell you
a little bit about our result in the
second setup under Bernoulli design
under Bernoulli design
um we're we are able to present an
estimator that allows for non-uniform
treatment but it does require knowledge
of the graph I think the value of
allowing for non-uniform treatment is
that it allows you to extend it to
observational settings where you where
you believe you could estimate these
treatment probabilities and and impose
some uncomfoundedness assumptions then
it implies that the results actually
directly extend to an observational
setup as well a limited observational
setup
so here
um again to uh I'll present the
intuition in the linear model so here
um recall we have our treatments that go
on outgoing edges you can think of that
as selecting Columns of this Matrix
again this Matrix is our Matrix of
unknown parameters and the measurements
are on the incoming edges so the
measurements are row sums of the
selected columns
that's a again that and the thing we
want to estimate is the sum of all the
entries in this uh Matrix that are
unknown
so the estimatory approach looks like
this
um uh there's a term on the right in the
inside inner term looks a little bit
like inverse probability weights but the
sum here is non-standard where I'm going
to multiply the outcome of an end of of
an individual by the sum of of all these
inverse probability weights of all its
neighborhood
but we can show this estimator is
unbiased and indeed the variance scales
as 1 over n times P so again in the
linear setting this is the best we it is
actually you know best we can expect
and we can extend it to a polynomial
model it looks uh and the estimator
looks just slightly more complicated but
again you're summing you're multiplying
each of the outcomes by a function now
which which is a sum of all the subsets
of the neighborhood of some again a
quantity that looks kind of like an
inverse probability weights and the
estimator is indeed equivalent to the
Harvest Thompson estimator the fully
General estimator if our degree is large
if beta is larger than the degree of the
graph so in particular if we don't put
any constraints this does reduce to the
most General estimator as well
and we can show that this estimator is
also unbiased and indeed the variance of
this estimated scales as one over n
times P to the beta so again the the
main
um
um kind of gain is you can see that if
uh beta is significantly smaller than
the degree then we show that the the
kind of the exponential part of the
dependence of the variance instead of
scaling with the degree of the graph
scales with the complexity uh this this
new model complexity that we're
proposing
um so we we do also some experiments
um uh comparing our estimator again
against ordinary least squares
um also uh also a difference means
estimators we can get very similar
looking results
um where our estimator is in the one in
blue in this s uh in this setting um the
variance is it is a little higher than
the OLS estimator so the OLS estimators
are the purple and the red estimators
those have significantly smaller
variants but have
um have some bias and so if your sample
if your population size is large enough
then the the fact that our estimator is
unbiased will end up being still
um
lead to lower mean squared error
um so yeah I'll wrap it up with a few
the minutes for questions so in
conclusion we we've shown you estimators
that exploit the structure of these
potential outcomes model
um to estimate the total treatment
effect under Network interference and we
characterize the complexity of these um
um of the potentials model with a low
polynomial degree which you can think of
as low order interactions amongst the
neighborhood and furthermore if we have
staggered rollout design so a more ex
richer experimental setup where we can
take multiple measurements at different
treatment levels it does enable fully
graph agnostic estimators that don't
require knowledge of the network at all
and furthermore we can extend
um uh to some some settings of
uncomfounded observational settings if
you have knowledge of the network
and there are many open questions in
this space I think um you know you can
ask uh how do you construct the best
estimator for General randomized designs
or even can you optimize the randomized
design
um if you uh had knowledge of the graph
structure and you had the ability to
um there's actually some very uh
interesting work by Stefan wagger at
Stanford with his student looking at um
a um a more restrictive model than we
look at but they actually impose a graph
on generative model on the graph and
show that if the graphon has a low rank
structure they can actually use the low
rank structure to construct a more
efficient estimator
um that has you know reduced has reduced
variance when the degree of the graph
could be large so I think there's
definitely a lot of interesting
questions around there for optimally
using network structure if you
um if you had it and
um also interesting would be how do you
extend these Beyond just neighborhood
models uh can we optimally incorporate
covariates handle unobserved confounders
or also compute valid and efficient
confidence intervals so I think this
last point of how do you
um how do you show Central limb ethereum
style results for a graph setting where
the outcomes are correlated because of
the graph structure is also a very
interesting question
um okay and I'm happy to take questions
foreign
hi Christina thanks so much for the
great talk
um I'm wondering um so you mentioned at
some point about going to the
observational setting right
um
would in that case do you then would you
then need to assume that even if it's an
observational setting the assignments to
the individual vertices are independent
or can they actually be correlated
depending on the network structure yeah
so what you what we can handle
um is for example
um suppose uh I'm I suppose what I'm
allowed to do is I'm not actually able
to assign treatment but I can encourage
treatment
um so I can run an experiment where
um I can uh uh or yeah okay maybe maybe
I could actually no I can offer
treatment but an individual has to
decide whether to follow through or not
meaning that I can randomize over the
offer of the treatment but I cannot
control if individual takes it or not
and so subsequently whether an
individual actually takes the treatment
is a function both of whether I offered
it as well as
um whether they choose to take it so if
it's the case that there that it could
be that um individuals
um probability of whether they would
adopt the treatment if it was offered to
them it could be a strong a function of
their
um uh like their covariates so or not
even whether observed or uncovered so
their type so uh what and that type
could be observed could be unobserved
that's the setting that we can handle
the reason why that is because when
since we're just randomizing the offer
uh that that randomization still gives
enough Independence
um but the the
um but the probability that individual
takes a treatment or not could be
different amongst different individuals
but coral and that probability could be
correlated to whether or not they you
know their type
um because of that I mean but but that
that's a particular study we can map to
a non-uniform for newly treatment
setting
so there's some kinds of uh so main
thing is that we have to assume that
conditioned on some uh observed features
that we can control for that
subsequently the treatments are
independent from uh anything we don't
condition on
uh assumption we need for the
authorizational setting but it's not as
restrictive as randomized experiment
the questions
I have a quick question I was wondering
like how do you know it's causal
relationship not say correlation
relationship
uh that's where we heavily use the
random the randomization part of it um
because the the randomized like big uh
because we're um
because we're actually assigning the
treatments randomly it
um it it
breaks the it means that any differences
we see are truly due to uh not not uh
like because we're assigning the
treatments randomly there's not
variation on the treatments being
um selectively assigned to certain
groups rather than others and so it it
allows us to then
um
can translate the inference result to a
causal one
but that's why if we want to make any
conclusions like that on observational
data we would need additional
assumptions that once we condition on
The observed covariates that then there
is uh subsequently there is Independence
between the treatments
and the outcomes
other questions
um okay if not let's thank you again
[Applause]
thanks and I look forward to see you all
soon